هذا النفق هو قد يكون الاطول في العالم
بممتد من منطقه داعل في شمال درعا في
سوريا باتجاه سهل الحوران الى منطقه لواء
الرمثا اضطره كفرسون سمر ابدر فام قيس في
لواء بني كنانه
[موسيقى]
اليوم احنا بهذا التجربه وهي تجربه
تفاعليه ضفنا منتج سياحي جديد على
الفعاليات الممكن تنفيذها نهاريا اليوم
هذا النفق راح يكون عنصر جذب رئيسي
للمجموعات السياحيه ولرحلات المدرسيه بحيث
انه بتطيل من مده اقامه الزائر وبرضو
بيرفض القطاع السياحي بمنتج اضافي للترويج
للجماليات الاستثنائيه الموجوده في شمال
المملكه هذا النفق في الواقع ساعد بتطور
الحركه السياحيه داخل مدينه ام قيس حيث في
شهر خمسه تقريبا ما يقرب من 35 الف زائر
زار مدينه ام قيس ومن ضمنها اللي هو
الترويج
للموقع الاثري
ولزياره النفق
يعني حتى وانت ماشيه التجربه حلوه اولا
يو كان سي طبقات الصخور بطريقه كثير حلوه
انه حتى الوان الصخور بتتغير شبر شبر
بتغير اللون تبع الصخور
تجربه جدا رائعه اول شيء انا كنت كتير
خايفه اني اجربها لاني انا بخاف من اماكن
المسكره وخفت انه صار شوي عند ارتفاع
نبضات قلب بس المهم انها كانت تجربه كتير
جميله كتير حلوه رائعه الجو هون اشي كتير
غريب يعني قد ما بسمع وتوقعت يعني ما
توقعت تكون هيك الجو الهواء
الصخر
المعلومات كل شي كان جدا رائع
[موسيقى]